التفاصيل الجديده في قضيه سرقه مليارين
ونصف الملياردولار من اموال الضرائب سلطت
الضوء كما ذكرنا على بيئه الفساد في
العراق بيئه محميه بالسلاح والنفود
السياسيه ثنائيه تضمن بقاء مثل هذه
الملفات الكبرى سريه للغايه كشفه بعض
الملفات الفساد سيكشفوا معه تورط جهه
الخارجيه وهنا الاصابع تتجه شرقا حيث
ايران
وجماعته عملت عبرها ايران لي اضاعه الفرص
العراقيه لاسيا في اتفاقيه الاطار
الاستراتيجيين مع واشنطن وبدايا لوقف
الدعم الماليه الامريكيه كيف ذلك
الحكومات العراقيه عبرعها ما يجعل تحالف
واشنطن مع بغداد على المحك دائما فافضمن
ايران اقتصاد العراقيه ضعيفا وفي حاله
فوضى دائما وفي ملف الطاقه والكهرباء اكبر
دليل
في تصريح لنا سابق يعود الى العام 2018
نائب رئيس الوزراء الاسبق بهاء الاعرجي في
حكومه حيدر العبادي اتهم ايران بعرقله
مشاريع لتطوير الطاقه والكهرباء في العراق
المصلحه واضحه ايران لا تسمح لاي حكومه
بتنميت هذا القطاع عبر ابروعها لتبقى
بغداد مرهونه للغاز الايراني
كبيرا يستملك نحو احد عشر مصرفا في العراق
كما ان لها حصصا في سته مصاريف اخرى بقيمه
تتجاوز السبعين مليار دولار ولا يخفى على
العراقيين ان زاد العملات الاجنبيه وما
يدور حوله من شبهات فساد تطال شخصيه
سياسيه نافذه تدير
لاداره هذه الملفات
غرفه الصخر حديقه الحرس الثوري والشاه
الولائيه تلك الناحيه الاستراتيجيه خارج
السلطه الدوله مواردها منهوبه واهلها
مشردون ولا يملكون حق العوده
والفساد المستشار في البلاد ليس جديدا فهو
مستمر منذ
وسبب بهدر اكثر
من مليار دولار سبق السوداني في هذا الملف
كله من رئيس الوزراء الاسبق حيدر العبادي
ومن بعده الكاظمي اللذين حقق انجازات
المحدوده في بعض الملفات
تشكي له رجال الخاصه بمحاربه الفساد والتي
تاخذ على عتيقها فتح الملفات وجلب
المتهمين الى العداله عاده ما تصطدم اما
بوجود تسويه سياسيه
ويغلق الملف على اثرها او يتم تهريب
والمتهمين الى خارج البلاد يعلق بعض
العراقيين امالهم على السوداني خاصه في ظل
تغيير هيئه النزاهه وتشكيل لجنه المسانده
لمكافحه الفساد لكن اخرين يرون انه لم
يذهب بعيدا في ملف في الفساد الذي تقف
خلفه الكتل السياسيه التي تدير المشهد
السياسيه